- My friend says,
"Hey, my sister brought
back all these free posters.
You want some?"
Now, why would the
Soviet Union give away
free propaganda posters to
naive stupid Westerners?
So I remember-
- You can't imagine why.
- Choosing one of
Lennon and thinking,
"Well, that sort of looks okay."
And I put it up, I was living
off campus, in my room.
My mom and dad came to visit
and my father looked at it,
and he looked at me and he said,
"Eric, could I speak
with you for a minute?"
And it suddenly dawned on me.
My father said, "I
wanna ask you favor.
Would you take that down?"
And it was as if the
scales fell from my eyes
and I realized what
has happened to me.
There are a hundred
other examples
but those are the two
moments that I remember
suddenly coming to
myself and thinking,
how is it possible that I
thought it was okay to do that
when my father raised
me to despise communism
the way Solzhenitsyn and
Buckley despised communism?
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is The Rubin Report.
Don't forget guys to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
and click that pesky
notification bell.
And joining me today
is a New York Times'
best selling author,
the host of The Eric
Metaxas radio show
and a senior fellow at
King's College in New York.
Eric Metaxas, welcome
to The Rubin Report.
- Thank you so much.
I'm also now a senior
fellow at the Falkirk Center
at Liberty University.
Ever so slightly conservative
folks down there.
- Can you be a senior fellow
at two different places?
Is that possible?
Is that not a
conflict of interest?
- If they don't listen to
this, then the answer is yes.
- I hate to tell
you, but I do have
a lot of fans at
Liberty University.
I spoke there and they
could be watching this.
- Can I tell you, no I love
them and I love Charlie Kirk
and I've just just done that.
Just become a senior
fellow with Falkirk
so it's a wonderful thing.
- Well, listen man, I'm
very happy to have you here
because I'm gonna do a
mea culpa right up front.
I was on my book tour, as
you know, for about a month,
just sitting in this chair,
being interviewed by,
I probably did
hundreds of interviews
and you were one of the
people that interviewed me.
And I did not know who you
were before you interviewed me.
I'm just saying it.
I have now done a tremendous
amount of research.
You've written
four billion books.
I found you to be one
of the most interesting,
insightful, curious
wordsmith interviewers
of all the people
that I talked to,
and I wanted to
return the favor.
So that's just me getting
it out of the way here.
- First of all, that
is so nice of you,
and you didn't need to do that.
That's like people say,
"I had a really, really
hateful thought toward you
seven years ago and I
wanted to confess it."
And you think, "I wish
he hadn't told me that.
Why did you have to do that?"
No, I wouldn't expect you
to be aware of me, Dave,
but you're very
kind to say that.
And the listen,
here's the point,
you're aware of me now, I'm
aware of you, we're all good.
- We're also dressed the same
and our hair is
sort of similar-ish,
so we're in good company.
But you're a really
established guy.
You've done a ton
of great things
and written several great books.
So for anyone in my
audience that does not know
who Eric Metaxas is, I just
read through your whole bio
and all sorts of
interesting stuff.
You were born in New York City.
It seems like no one's actually
born in New York City.
(indistinct)
But very few people born there
- I had to be.
I had to be.
My mom came from Germany
on a boat in the mid '50s,
my dad came from
Greece on a boat.
They met in an English
class here in New York City
to learn how to speak English.
And when a Greek man is
involved in having a family,
that kid has to be born
legally in Astoria, New York.
So that's why, I
was born in Astoria,
that's where I started life,
Jackson Heights, Queens,
but I spent most of my life
in Danbury, Connecticut.
- Correct me if I'm wrong,
you have to be born into
a bed of fettuccines.
Is that true or-
- You know something,
very few people know that.
Very few people know that,
because that's not
true, but still,
I understand what you're saying.
- Nonetheless.
Okay, before we
get to your books,
and I wanna talk about
your feelings on Trump
and the culture wars,
and we'll do some economics
and all sorts of stuff,
tell me a little bit
about what got you
into this talking world
of radio and writing,
and all of that stuff.
What is the ethos
of Eric Metaxas?
- I've gotta give you
the super quick version
'cause otherwise we'll
be here for the full hour
talking about it.
Basically, I am the
son of immigrants.
My parents still have
accents and they raised me
like most immigrants to
this country in the '50s
and any time before the '60s.
They raised me to love America
because they knew
how wonderful it was
having come from places.
My mother escaped East Germany
when she was 17 years old
because of the propaganda
coming to her in high school.
My father saw the Civil War
with the communists in Greece
in the early '50s.
So they came here,
they love America,
they taught me to love America
and they raised me with basic
homespun,
middle-American values.
We went to church every Sunday,
but we weren't born again or
evangelicals, if you're Greek.
I always say, if
you're born Greek,
if your parents are
Greek and German,
you will be raised Greek.
There's no option that
you're gonna be raised
any other way except full Greek,
so we went to church and stuff.
And when I went to Yale,
the American dream,
my parents didn't
get to go to college.
I get to go to Yale University.
Well, of course what happens,
young Eric drinks the woke
Kool-Aid of the early '80s,
and my world view, I would
have considered myself
roughly speaking,
conservative and Christian.
Before I know it I'm
taught, oh no, no, no,
that's bigoted and
small-minded and parochial.
So by the time I graduated,
I was totally lost.
I was not exactly an
activist woke person,
but the people political
correctness bug
hit some of those top
institutions early
and I was one of those
just confused people
who had a vaguely
anti-American sense of things.
I really betrayed all the things
that my parents had taught me,
and so I was very confused.
Now, the one thing that
happened when I was in college
is that I knew that I
wanted to be a writer.
I originally thought I
want to go to politics,
but I started reading the great
works of The Western Canon.
And it's one of these
things, it's like a gene.
I immediately said,
"This is what I wanna do.
I want to write, I love
words, I love ideas."
But I didn't know what I
wanted to write exactly.
So I won some awards at
Yale for my fiction writing.
I was the editor of the
humor magazine there.
I knew I had a
career in writing,
but it really wasn't
until I graduated
that I realized how lost I was.
'Cause now you don't have
the guard rails of academia
to keep you, this is
what I'm doing today.
This is what I'm doing today.
Suddenly I'm lost,
I wanna be a writer,
but I don't have a
worldview other than I know,
sort of how I'm
supposed to think.
And I went through
some really tough years
where I was just lost.
I wasn't some bold sinner,
I was just totally lost.
What's the meaning of life.
Can you know whether
life has a meaning?
Is there a God?
I always say that if
you get a good job,
you won't have time to
think about that stuff.
And I think that's the
ethos of a place like Yale,
all these institutions,
their idea is we ceased
about 100 years ago
answering the big questions.
What's the meaning of life?
Is there a God?
What's the meaning of your life?
Where do you go when you die?
Where do we come from?
We don't go there.
They don't go there.
So what they tell you is like,
study really hard,
get a great job,
and you'll be able to distract
yourself for a few decades
and then it'll all be over.
So just do whatever you do.
Don't think about
the big questions.
Well, I was an English
major, I wanna be a writer,
guess what happened?
I didn't get a good job.
I had several years to think
about the big questions.
And it got so bad
that I ended up
moving back in with my parents.
If your parents are
European immigrants,
working-class European
immigrants who sent you to Yale,
you do not wanna move
back in with them.
Trust me on this one.
- Right.
- It was pure hell.
And in the midst of that hell,
I did the only thing
that you could do,
which is I got a job
as a proofreader,
at Union Carbide Corporation
in Danbury, Connecticut.
I'm living with my parents
and I'm going to a chemical
conglomerate to do,
like, it was pure hell.
And in the midst of that hell,
I met a guy who was
pretty serious Christian
and he begins sharing
his faith with me.
And I had the standard
Yale response like,
don't get too close
with that weird stuff.
But I was in enough pain that
I was listening a little bit.
And this kind of cat
and mouse game went on
for about a year.
And I would say
roughly a year into it,
the cat to the chase,
I had a very dramatic
conversion dream.
It was one of those things
like it's out of a book.
It was a miracle, nothing else
could've sufficed to drag me
across the broomstick into
another universe basically
'cause I thought all
those people are insane.
So I had this
miraculous conversion
and I've spent the last 30
years trying to process this,
reading books and stuff.
But it was because of that
that I very quickly
became a conservative.
I think it was the pro-life
issue and a few other issues
that I just thought, wow.
I remember also, I was watching
the Bork hearings on TV.
Imagine, and I thought,
"Well, holy cow, the guys
that I would have voted for
are really evil.
They're really bad."
So I had this kind
of experience.
So ever since then,
I've known I wanted
to be in the culture.
I knew I wanted to be a writer,
I wasn't sure what
I wanted to write,
but I always had a dream
of doing a mainstream
TV talk show,
kind of like Dick Cavett,
who's become a friend,
because I think we need to have
those kinds of conversations.
And wouldn't it be
nice if the host
had more traditional,
more conservative,
more faith friendly views
than most of the people do.
So that's the long answer.
Would you prefer
the short answer,
I can give it to you later.
- It's a little late
for that Metaxas,
but to prove to you
I'm a good interviewer,
now what you did there as
the guest in this case,
was give me 100 off-shoots.
There's a hundred outlets
to go to right now,
and I wanna get back to-
- That's my goal.
- I wanna get back to
a lot of the things
you talked about there,
from the secularism on steroids,
which is what you're
describing Yalers
to the big questions they
were forcing you to avoid.
And a whole slew
of other things.
But let's back up a
little bit further.
You described the
immigrant family
and you went into college
somewhat conservative.
Do you remember the moments
where that started breaking up?
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- Or where the ideas
were really infecting you?
Can you talk about that
a bit?
- I've actually,
I'll never forget
it and I, in fact,
I have just finished writing
the memoir of my life
that takes me up
to my 25th birthday
and this dramatic
conversion dream.
And in there I write
about these two things.
Basically, first of
all, I was hanging out
with a lot of different people.
But the general middle year
was secular humanist liberal.
No question about it.
And I was, by being
raised the way I was,
I bumped into this
like, what's this?
I didn't know that, oh,
you can't say Oriental,
you have to say Asian.
You can't say, like
suddenly I was getting
all of these things that,
oh, you can't do that,
you can't do this,
and I was like,
"Oh, so I was raised by people
who didn't know this stuff,
but now I'm at Yale where
everybody knows everything.
These are the future leaders
and I'm just gonna
go along with them.
So you're picking this stuff up.
But I remember two
instances, this is classic.
I remember I was, we had a vote.
Nothing has changed
in all these years.
We were having a vote
whether our class funds
should divest from corporations
that were involved
in South Africa.
Because it was right before
a part that I broke up
and everything like that.
And what I find interesting
is that there was
only one way to vote.
In other words, it wasn't like,
let's actually think about this.
It was kind of the woke thing,
like, are you gonna
say hail Hitler or not,
you're gonna take a knee or not?
We're not giving you choices.
You know what you need to do?
Are you gonna do it?
Here's your opportunity to
do it and to show solidarity.
So everybody voted
the right way,
except a friend of mine who
oddly enough is a Democrat,
but he was an economics
major, and he said,
"No, I don't actually
think it's gonna help
the people of South
Africa if we do that."
So he voted, okay,
a different way.
But here's the key.
The next day in the dining hall,
a very dear friend of
mine comes up to me
who was involved in this
voting process and he says,
"Hey, your buddy
Chris, he voted no."
And I'll never forget, it's
as if my whole upbringing
came to me and I thought,
"This is America.
You mean you looked at his vote
and you dare to tell me
that he voted the wrong way
as though it wasn't
an actual election.
That's what they
do in Red China."
I remember being chilled,
just being horrified.
Not too long after that,
I had an experience
where a friend of mine's sister,
and I imagine this
is still Reagan.
So a friend of mine's sister
went to the Soviet Union.
This is like all the
woke Manhattan elites
send their kids to
whatever schools
and there's a semester in
Moscow to study economics.
And she brought back a
ton of propaganda posters.
So my friend says,
"Hey, my sister brought
back all these free posters.
You want some?"
Now, why would the
Soviet Union give away
free propaganda posters to
naive stupid Westerners?
So I remember-
- You can't imagine why.
- Choosing one of
Lennon and thinking,
"Well, that sort of looks okay."
And I put it up, I was living
off campus, in my room.
My mom and dad came to visit
and my father looked at it
and he looked at me and he said,
"Eric, could I speak
with you for a minute?"
And it suddenly dawned on me.
My father said,
"I wanna ask you favor,
would you take that down?"
And it was as if the
scales fell from my eyes
and I realized, what
has happened to me.
There are a hundred
other examples
but those are the two
moments that I remember
suddenly coming to
myself and thinking,
how is it possible that I
thought it was okay to do that
when my father raised
me to despise communism,
the Solzhenitsyn and
Buckley despised communism?
- So what's interesting
about this to me,
there's couple of things
but particularly is
that if you listen
to mainstream media now,
this idea of the
woke college thing,
people think it's an idea
of the last five years
or something like that.
Or it's just this last
millennial generation
that's going through it.
What years were you in college?
- I was there, I
graduated in '84.
But it was in full swing.
It was in full swing
in the early '80s.
And look, let's be honest,
this stuff started
at least in 1968.
It's only a matter of
the trickle down effect.
When did it get
to the mainstream?
And the fact of the matter is
that Yale and places like that
are they're the worst offenders
of this kind of stuff.
If I ever had money, I
wouldn't give them money.
They are the absolute
worst offenders.
They have been leading the
charge with this kind of stuff.
So I saw this maybe earlier
than a lot of other people did,
but it was an
absolute full force.
- So I feel like
we gotta talk about
that dream a little bit.
Because you told
me you had a dream
and it changed your life,
but we need to know some
details on this thing.
- Yeah.
Well I always tell people
to go to my website to
watch the video of the dream
because it's very hard to,
I will try because I like you.
I will try very hard
to be more (indistinct)-
- Much obliged.
than I was in the
first question.
It's tricky stuff.
I'll tell you why.
And this is, I wrote a
whole book on miracles,
and sometimes what makes a
miracle dramatic is the context.
In other words, if God
is speaking to someone,
it may make sense to that person
because they bring a
whole bunch of context
to that situation
and it wouldn't mean
anything to anyone else.
In my case, if you had
put a gun to my head
at age 24 and said, who are you?
In a dream or in a
fairytale, in your core,
who are you?
I don't think I could
have come up with it.
But the most basic
elements, if they were,
let's say three of who
I was at that point
were the Greek
immigrant upbringing
was at the center of my life.
There's no question.
And the second thing
was that for all of my
teen years or childhood or
whatever, I was fishing.
When I wasn't watching TV,
when I wasn't watching
"Sanford and Son"
and "The Dean Martin
Roast," I was fishing.
And that's just what I did.
So I never got in trouble.
I studied, I watched TV,
and I did a lot of fishing,
so that was a big part of me.
But also a weird connection
is that my father,
whenever he saw, 'cause
all Greeks are evangelists
for being Greek.
Their number one
hobby is being Greek.
And so my father,
anytime he saw a fish,
a chrome fish on the back
of a car in the '70s,
he would say, you see that fish?
That comes from the Greek word,
because the early
Christians couldn't use
the sign of the cross,
they used the symbol of the fish
because the Greek word for fish,
the ancient word is ichthys,
it's where we get ichthyologist.
And ichthys, the
words, it's an acronym,
(speaking in foreign language)
It spells Jesus Christ,
the son of God our savior.
And so they use the
secret symbol of the fish
and my father says to me
in Danbury, Connecticut,
on the highway,
"You see that fish,
it's a Greek word."
And he gets all excited about
the fact that it's Greek.
Now, I'm being a little unfair.
I think he was aware of
the Christian element,
but he was very excited that
the fish, it's a Greek word.
So in any event, the
third part of me,
if you're gonna say
there's fishing,
there's the Greek thing,
the third part of me
was what I call the
life of the mind.
From age 16 to 24,
I'm trying to figure
out the meaning of life.
I'm trying to figure out,
who am I, why am I here?
And whenever I was
reading the literature
that I was reading in college,
I wasn't reading it the
way most people read it.
I was trying to figure out
what is the clue to humanity?
Who are we?
And it's good art,
that's what it does.
It helps you understand what
does it mean to be human
and so on and so forth.
So I was trying to
puzzle this out,
and I remember
that at some point,
just after graduating and
getting the woke memo,
that Christianity
is too parochial,
the Bible, it's just a
bunch of right bigots.
But if there's any religion,
it probably combines
all religions,
and it's probably more
like a new age life force
or something like that.
And I came up with
this idea in my own,
that you know what, it's
sort of like Freud's idea
of the soul.
Where you have
the conscious mind
and then you have
the unconscious below
the conscious mind.
And I kind of brought
in a little Jung,
this is supposed to
sound pretentious.
I was an undergraduate.
So I have this idea, that
maybe the goal of life is that
the ice on the lake
is the conscious mind.
And that the water beneath
it is the unconscious
or what Yong calls the
collective unconscious,
which is this God force
or something like that.
And I thought maybe
that's what all religions
are getting at.
So the goal of life is
to drill through the ice
so that you have an an
emotionally healthy connection
between the conscious mind and
the collective unconscious,
or God or whatever it is.
Now, what does that
mean practically?
Bupkis, nothing, of course.
It just means like, yeah, I
figured that out, I got it.
All religions say the same thing
and I'm gonna move
on with my life.
So that's really where
I was coming from,
which of course led
me to be really lost.
How do I live?
What is right, what is wrong?
I had no idea.
So I meet this guy.
He talks to me about my
faith and faith whatever,
we talked for about a year.
And at the end of the
year, I had a dream.
My uncle had just passed away
so I was a little bit
emotionally vulnerable
and beginning to wonder, is
there something out there?
And if there is, I feel
like I'm hermetically sealed
in a room with no
windows and no doors.
And if there's a God out there,
he's gonna have to punch a hole
through the wall
and say, I'm here.
Because in the material world,
I have no way of
logically getting there.
So in this dream, I'm
standing on a frozen lake
in Danbury,
Connecticut, Candlewood,
where I fish many times.
And I looked down
and in the hole,
and this never happens if
you're an ice fishermen,
there's a fish sticking
its snout out of a hole.
And I reached down and I
pick it up by the gills,
and it's like a
pickerel or a pike.
It's one of those bronze,
golden-colored fish.
And I pick it up and
it's one of these,
in a dream like this, I'd
never had a dream like this
ever in my life, nor since.
It was like the
perfect winter day
where the snow and the
ice are super white
and the sky is super blue,
and it's just glorious.
And I hold up this golden
fish into the sunlight.
And in the dream, suddenly I
know, this is the golden fish.
This is ichthys.
This is all, God's one up
to me with my symbol system
and these two paragraphs dropped
into my head in the dream,
that you wanted to touch
inert water, this God force,
but I had something
else for you,
my son, your savior,
Jesus Christ, ichthys.
And this all came
together in the dream.
And the weird thing
is in the dream,
I'm holding this fish up,
and I realized in the dream,
it looks golden as though
it's actually made of gold,
and then I realized
in the dream,
no, it is made of gold.
It is a golden fish that
is nonetheless alive,
like out of a fairytale.
And at that moment in the dream,
my mind was totally blown.
I knew that God had my number,
that he spoke to me in a
way that made sense to me,
that the thing that I
had convinced myself
was impossible for
intelligent people to know,
you could maybe
hope that it's true.
That suddenly I knew
it, I was stuck with it.
I would have to deal with
it for the rest of my life
but I couldn't go back,
I couldn't pretend that
God hadn't spoken to me
in this miraculous way,
which revealed that
he knew more about me
than I knew about myself.
Now that is the short
version of it, I apologize.
- No, no, no.
Well, there's a lot
there, so let's go.
So when you have this,
now you have this
revelation, let's say.
- Yeah.
- You're obviously
an intellectual guy.
That seems to be where
much of the thrust
of your passion is.
Did you freak out after that,
like this was
gonna somehow erode
the intellectual
side of yourself?
- No.
- Or turn you in the
eyes of your friends,
something like that?
- Well, yes.
Well, for sure, I knew
that would happen.
But this is where, I mean, look,
let's say you're in the
woods and you meet Bigfoot,
and you know you're not an
idiot, you're not on mushrooms,
it actually happened.
There are people that are
never gonna believe you,
but you're stuck.
You can't convince yourself
that it didn't happen.
It's one of those things
where, when I woke up,
I knew this was real,
I knew this was true,
I knew the Bible is the word
of God, I know Jesus is way,
and I knew all my friends
would think I'm nuts
or pat me on the head
and go like, whatever.
But the point is I
didn't have a choice.
I couldn't say, you know what,
I'm just gonna ignore this.
It was too powerful to ignore.
It wasn't something
I could walk from.
It was God crafting a
message literally for me,
in a way, calculated by
the author of the universe
to blow my mind.
My mind was blown.
But the funny thing
is, Dave, that I knew,
I remember going to work the
next day to tell my friend,
this Christian who
had been talking to me
and I tell him a little
bit about the dream,
he goes, "What do
you think it means?"
And I said, "I've
accepted Jesus."
Now, I would've never,
I would have cringed
to speak those words
anytime before.
But I said it to
him like, it's done.
Whatever that means,
that's what happened now.
I didn't start voting for
Republicans the next day.
It took a time for me to begin
to process this,
but I knew that I would
challenge most of my friends,
would be tough for them.
And the ones who were
willing to hear me out
and to continue to be my friend,
that's kind of where you realize
who your real friends are,
in a sense, because they
accorded me enough dignity
to try to understand
what I was telling them.
And the funny thing too, is that
I never was a like in
your face about it,
but they acted as though I was.
I remember having
lunch here in Manhattan
with a sophisticated
friend, and saying,
just kind of telling him this
in a very, very gingerly,
and him sort of exploding, like,
"What are you saying?
Everybody's going to hell."
He just is all over me.
And I just thought,
this is what,
this is gonna be
the rest of my life.
But it's not that different
from coming out for Trump.
Some people are gonna hate you,
some people are gonna
think you're evil.
Some people are gonna love you.
The fact of the matter
is that at some point
you have no choice.
When that happened in the
summer of 1988, I had no choice.
I had to do my best to
represent it as I could.
And I've many ways failed
and in some ways succeeded,
but there's just no
going back from that.
I wanted a miracle,
I got a miracle.
And I've had many miracles
that have happened to me
actually since then,
which I give the,
they rise to the bar of
calling them miracles.
I'm not talking about
blessings, oh that was nice.
That is real, I've
experienced it,
not as much as I would like.
But at this point
we could debate
all kinds of stuff forever,
but if somebody asks me, are
you sure about the Jesus,
are you sure have it?
There was no question.
You can torture me,
there's nothing I can
do to convince myself
that I might've missed
something at this point.
- So speaking of miss something,
then do you think
that most academics,
like your friend that you
sat with who brought up
burning in hell
and the rest of it,
do you think that that
is the fundamental flaw
of most academics
that then is partly
why we're watching
academia crumble right now,
that they've
disconnected these things
or they've mocked believers
to the point that they've
been left with this?
I'll just mention
one other thing,
which is I had John Kasich,
the former governor of Ohio
on, he's the governor of Ohio.
And he said something
interesting to me about this.
He said, "You know, a lot of
people can do it without God.
I'm just not one
of those people."
And I brought it up in
many interviews since then.
Because it's not
the most enlightened
thing I've ever heard,
it's actually very
humbling and decent,
and I found it to be
really refreshingly honest.
Do you sense there's
some connection there
between the way the
intellectual elite
seem to be crumbling right now?
- There's zero question
that the answer is yes.
There's no question.
Look, it's all related.
It's not just about God.
I'll give an example,
at a place like Yale,
if you are somebody like
Miroslav Volf, okay.
He's a serious Christian,
but he's pretty left wing.
So they'll give him a pass.
It really is, but
it's very interesting,
what are the different
shibboleths that people have?
It's like, you can
say anything you want,
but if you don't believe
a woman should be able
to kill what's in her womb,
you're a pig and a bigot.
And it's interesting
how that works out.
And I think that academia,
it's funny 'cause I've
written about this.
You can trace this way
back to the '20s, really,
that it's like we
were saying earlier
that there's this
trickle down effect.
These ideas were
seeded S-E-E-D-E-D,
seeded into the
culture in many ways.
From Darwin to Nicha
to Freud, whatever.
But they came into the
culture big time in the '20s.
Margaret Mead was popular,
having sex with anyone
you like in Samoa.
This kind of vague
Freudian scientific reason
for doing as we liked
became popularized.
But it didn't trickle
down to middle America
until you get to the '60s.
And it still didn't trickle
down to the effected,
continues to trickle down,
so that now we have
arsonists and looters,
and potential murderers
who are pretending
to care about the
death of a black man
in the way that Martin
Luther King Jr.,
Rosa Parks, Jackie
Robinson would spit on them
for the desecration
of the memory
of those who have suffered
under real racism.
The dissent from true American
self-government and Liberty
into cultural Marxism
doesn't happen overnight,
but that's effectively
what we're looking at.
And Christianity to me,
in many ways has been
at the core of this.
There's just no question that
when you talk about the West,
and it's part of the reason
for the decline of Europe,
when you jettison
the Christianity,
what do you have exactly?
If they were unwilling
to put mention of God
in the European parliament,
in their constitution,
you think, well then, so tell
me, what exactly is Europe?
So there's no question about it.
And again, there
are degrees of this
depending on who you talk to,
but there are certain
things, you know this,
that are simply not spoken
of in certain places
and faculty lounges
at places like Yale,
and The New York
Times boardroom,
and on and on and on and on,
they're, not gonna
touch that stuff.
They have been very happy
to allow the culture
to become dramatically secular.
- All right, so then this is
gonna be a hell of a segue.
Watch how I do it.
With all of that cultural
stuff you're talking about
in the academic elites, you've
written some children's book.
Books about Donald Trump.
- Yeah.
- I sense of connection there.
These are not coincidences.
- I actually, I
have to correct you,
and this is my fault
because I have let this go
without correcting people.
(indistinct)
No, I'll tell you what,
I've written 30 children's
books over the years.
But I've also written
a lot of humor.
I was the editor of the
humor magazine at Yale.
I wrote a parody of the old
"Ripley's Believe
It or Not" books
with St. Martin's Press
like 20 years ago.
I've written a lot of humor
and when I do public
speaking and stuff,
there's just a lot of
comedy and goofing around
on my radio program.
Some people think
of me as as funny.
So I had this idea
when Trump was elected-
- That's a good title
for a book, that's a
good title for a book.
Some people think
of me as funny.
(both laugh)
- I'm not gonna use it.
I give that to you.
- No, no, thank you.
- But the thing is that I
like humor, I like sad tale.
I've even published
humor in "The New Yorker"
and in "The Atlantic" and stuff.
I've loved that kind of thing.
And when Trump was
elected, I said to the guy,
my dear friend, Tim
Raglin who lives in Kansas
and he and I have done a
number of books together.
He's a genius illustrator.
This stuff we've done together
is just, it's stunning.
But I said to him, Tim you know,
you're the one that convinced me
to look differently at Trump,
when I was still like, I
don't know about that guy.
I'm a New Yorker and
he's sort of vulgar,
and I'm a Christian and
he's not my first pick.
And he had me look at him
differently and I said,
Trump is like, he's
like a folk hero.
He's like out of
one of these books
that I've written
with Tim Raglin,
he's larger than life
like a cartoon figure.
And I said to Tim,
"Tim, we need to do
like a children's book
about a character,
a Trump character,
but it's really adult satire
in the form of a
children's book."
Now, for example, I wrote a
lullaby book actually for kids
called "It's Time
to Sleep My Love."
Some guy decided
to parody that book
and use the title,
"Go the F to Sleep."
Now that sold a lot
more than my book,
but the point is, it looks
like a children's book
but it's obviously
meant for adults.
The thing with my book,
"Donald Drains the Swamp",
I just happen to
have a copy here,
"Donald Drains the Swamp," is
that even though it's aimed
at adults because there's
sophisticated humor,
for example, the turtle
just happens to look
like Mitch McConnell.
That's a coincidence
'cause all turtles
look like Mitch McConnell.
- It's not a coincidence.
- But the point is that
when you're talking about
the swamp and all of
this, there's a lot
of political humor.
But because there's
nothing nasty in it,
it works for kids.
So people often say
it's a kid's book.
It's a kid's book.
Technically, it's
an adult humor book,
it's a novelty book,
it's a satire book
and adults are gonna
get all the jokes.
Kids aren't gonna get the jokes.
They don't know who AOC is,
and they don't know
that Bernie is a
communist and they're...
So we've written
three of these books.
But a big reason that
we did them, as I said,
the one thing we conservatives
tend to be bad at
is creating culture.
We talk about
politics all the time,
but in terms of sitcoms
or children's books
or the world of publishing,
it tends to be taken
over by the left.
The left really has,
the long march through
the institutions,
academia, publishing,
journalism,
it's all very, very leftist.
And I said, I wanna create
something that's fun
for people who actually
liked this president.
And of course the
reason he's a Caveman
is meant to be funny.
'Cause he is kind of a Caveman.
You kind of think cavemen,
they see a problem,
they fix the problem.
They don't know that you're
not supposed to do it that way.
They just wanna fix the problem,
like they're good guys
and they just do it.
So it's not really
making fun of him,
but there's a lightness to it
for people who think of him
as somewhat of a Caveman.
- But Metaxas, I can see
the commenters already,
in the future, and
they're gonna say,
wait a minute, how can this
intellectual Christian,
talking about Jesus,
support the Caveman.
How can it possibly be?
- I support him because
I'm a Christian.
It's rather simple.
Look, the idea that...
I think you know this,
that there are people, and we
see this on the left today,
no matter what you do, they'll
find what's wrong with it.
Trump has made this so much
worse just by being Trump.
He's driven people insane,
so that if he says one
plus one equals two,
they're gonna say, I
don't know about that,
and some people
say it might not.
And in a quantum universe,
that's a lot of bologna
and he's too stupid
to understand
what a quantum universe is.
- And it's definitely racist.
It's also racist,
one plus one.
- And it's also,
we forgot to mention, goes
without saying it's racist.
So I think that the reason
that I support Trump is,
it's kind of weird
actually, I was writing
this humor piece
for The New Yorker,
called "More Trump
Bible Verses."
Cause there was that,
Contra Trump about him
not remembering
something for the Bible.
I found the whole
thing hilarious.
And so I did a whole thing
of tweets of Bible verses
that they're kind of Trumpian.
I wonder if I can remember
any of them right now,
but like a good wife who
can find, I found three.
Whatever, and there was
just all these Bible verses
that we have some dim memory of,
and then sort of a
Trumphication of it.
Anyway, while I was writing
it for The New Yorker,
this is totally true, I found
myself almost like a comedian,
because I have written
a lot of comedy,
like you're writing for a voice.
Like I'm writing for Bob Hope
or I'm writing for Jackie Mason
and you kind of find that
voice and you find that rhythm.
And I found myself having
an affection for him
in the way that you
would for an uncle
that he's not
politically correct.
There's a lot of stuff about him
that wouldn't work among your
friends, but you love him.
And you know he's a good man,
and you know he
loves his country,
and he would fight and
die for his country.
And if you're in trouble, you
want him around, he's good.
But he's rough around the edges
and he's got a lot of
things and you say,
please, don't say that.
Whatever you do,
please don't say that
when my friends are over there.
They're not gonna
understand that.
And I began to see
that side of him
and then I also realized
that because I grew up
in a working class environment,
he speaks to the working class.
Martin Luther, about
whom I've also written,
had this similar ability.
Even though Trump
went to Wharton
and is obviously an
instinctive genius.
There's no question about it,
but he has an ability to
connect with work and class,
and a big part of that
is humor and hyperbole.
And I began to hear
him differently, and
I began to think,
wow, the cultural elites,
they don't get that language.
It's like you may as well
be speaking Japanese.
They don't get it.
And so, I began to
appreciate him more and more.
But I have to say that if
anything ever revealed to me
how pathetic the Republican
Party had become,
when they turned against
him the way that he did,
I mean, his ability to
see the problem in China,
for example, we'll just
talk about a minor thing.
Really minor, right?
- Right, right.
- 1.3 billion people,
the level of seriousness
that our leaders
ought to have accorded China
over the last three decades
is so huge and they
basically ignored it
while it grew into a monster.
Trump, if he did nothing else,
diagnose the problem
30 years ago,
has been talking
about it for 30 years
and is now rather effectively
doing a number of things
to deal with this problem.
How much money is he making?
A lot less than Hunter
Biden is making on China?
I don't see him getting
anything out of it,
except he feels it's the
right thing for America.
So it's things like
that, that's just one.
But he has been very
staunchly pro-life
and staunchly religious liberty
and these are the things that
have concerned me deeply.
His willingness to
stand up for Kavanaugh.
I would bet that a
lot of Republicans,
people that I thought were
good guys 10 years ago,
they would've folded at the end.
And so, there's a
lot to recommend him
and you're not supposed
to vote for somebody
because you think they
share your theology.
I don't really think that's
why you elect the president.
It would be nice if he did,
but it's like saying that,
like, that pilot is not that
great, but he loves Jesus.
And that pilot is the best
pilot, whoever flew a plane,
but he's had four wives
and he's been in jail.
People make it sound like
it's a simple choice,
it's not as simple choice.
- Yeah.
Do live in New York
City right now?
- I live in Manhattan,
I'm here now,
and yeah, I live in Manhattan.
- The reason I ask is because
to espouse those radical views
that you've just
announced in Manhattan,
in a strange time to
live in Manhattan,
I assume you have two
locks on your door.
- Well, in all seriousness,
Dave, if you think about it,
being a born again
evangelical's not exactly
a popular way to
fly around here.
And I've always
been before Trump,
I believed in the
dignity of the unborn,
I take that very seriously.
I have a biblical
view of sexuality.
These are not popular
views in blue states.
But the point is that
this is where I'm from.
I try to be respectful of
people with whom I differ.
I don't lose friendships
over those things.
I love people with whom I
disagree on these things.
And so, the Trump thing
was just taking it
to the next level.
But it's kind of
funny, in our building,
there are three couples
that love Trump.
Two are Orthodox Jewish couples
and another, some kind of
Gentile couple, they love Trump.
I think there's a lot
of people in New York
who like him or love him,
but they just don't
say it publicly.
I don't wear a Manga
hat down Madison Avenue.
- Yeah.
As we're going through,
we're taping this
a little bit before
we're gonna air it
so I don't wanna get into
the exact nitty gritty
of what's happening today.
- Right, I know.
- But as we're going
through this national tumble
and all of this stuff
and the unraveling
of the fabric of America
that you described before,
your Greek father and
your German mother
and all of this stuff.
And as a guy that
lives in New York City,
and you just mentioned some
of the people in building,
are you worried that we're
gonna look back and go,
man, we had something that
was so freaking precious
and we didn't even realize it?
Perhaps the ship has even
sailed on that already.
- Funny you should bring that up
because I've thought about this
day and night for years now.
I wrote a book, I
don't have a copy here,
but if I could give a copy
to everyone in your audience,
everyone in America, it's
called, "If You Can Keep It."
Franklin was asked after the
constitutional convention,
Dr. Franklin-
- We're gonna get to it.
Let's do it right now.
(mumbles)
We'll link to it.
- But the fact of the matter
is that over the years,
because of my faith and
because of my, excuse me,
evolving political views, I
began to notice some things.
And I began to
notice, for example,
one of the reasons America is
great is that it's an idea.
It's not an ethnic tribal group.
Everybody, my father
with his Greek accent,
my mother with a German accent,
they can become as American
as George Washington.
That's a new concept in
the history of the world.
It's a beautiful concept.
And so, if it's true
that America is an idea
and if we're self-governing,
unless people know that idea,
understand how that works
and live out that idea
of governing themselves
and in a sense, teaching
others how to self-govern,
what this means, how fragile
and beautiful this is
and what we must do to keep it,
if we don't, it goes
away absolutely.
There's just no question.
There's no question
whether it will go away.
It will go away,
it's been going away.
So I wrote my book,
"If You Can Keep It"
specifically to put in a
small, easily readable book,
the very basics of what one
needs to know to get it.
Why you need to love your
country with all its flaws.
Why you must love your country.
Why you must fight for
Liberty, and on and on and on.
And I have to say in large
part, because I am a Christian,
I have hope when most
people wouldn't see hope.
I think God's had His
hand on this country.
Listen, Lincoln called us
the almost chosen people.
Now, why would he say that?
He said it because
he knew, he could see
that there was something.
In fact, he used the
phrase, something uncommon.
This is not just
another country.
If you believe that God has
had His hand on the Jews,
which I certainly do, that's
not something you party about.
It's a tremendous burden
to be chosen by God.
Because it means He's
going to use you,
and you're going to suffer
and it's not going to be easy.
And so God has blessed
this country amazingly,
but he's used this
country to export
liberty and wealth and on
and on, to the whole world,
because just as Israel
was created by God
to reach the whole world,
to reach the nations
outside of Israel,
America and all our
blessings are intended
for the rest of the world.
So we have something
that is so precious
and when I really understood
this, I wrote the book
and I have been on a mission.
Because I said,
"If we don't educate
the next generation
or even this generation,
it does go away."
And what we're seeing right now,
I think is the
heat of the battle.
We're in the midst of a battle
where we have a
president in a sense,
who by God's grace
has dragged us back
from the cliff of oblivion.
And so we have some time
to back away from the cliff.
But if Hillary had
been elected, which is,
you asked me earlier, how
could I vote for Trump?
I'm convinced that
that Hillary Clinton
and Obama and those folks,
are genuinely
tremendously corrupt.
In other words, that they
will put their own interests
before the interest of the
country, so that's strike three.
But I also believe that
their version of America,
their view of America is
fundamentally antithetical
to the founders' view.
The founder's view of
America, they don't share,
they want to undo it,
they have worked cleverly
over the decades to undo it
along with all the institutions
I mentioned earlier.
And I really believe that
had Hillary been elected,
for example, and instead
of Robertson, Kavanaugh,
we had gotten son of Sotomayor
and bride of Sotomayor,
if that had happened, it's over.
The constitution, just
because it's a piece of paper,
it's meaningless
unless we have judges
that are interpreting
things according to it,
unless we have people
that understand it.
So to me, there's no question
that we're right on that
precipice as it were.
- So I suspect you think that
even some of the Republicans
who you said before,
you might've liked,
or at one time supported
or something like that,
you think they
wouldn't have been able
to stand up against this
thing either, right?
- Oh, they weren't standing
up against it, they weren't.
Look, these are
people that I like,
but they were not
standing up against it.
It takes tremendous
courage to stand up against
what we now call the deep state.
The deep state is as tyrannical
as King George III was.
It is the enemy of
self-government and liberty.
And when I talk about liberty,
I'm not talking about some
French idea of liberty.
I'm talking about
God's idea of liberty
and how human beings
are supposed to live.
And if you don't go
to war with that,
if you play patty cake with
that because you thinks,
well, I don't wanna be the one,
the press already hates me,
eventually it's gonna get
worse and worse and worse.
And so I really think
that unfortunately
I can't understand how else
it could have happened.
But we have had leaders
who've been guilty
of what people have said
to me over the years
but I never believed it.
They're really no different
than the other side.
And I thought to myself,
that's true than I
would like to believe
when McCain voted against
overturning Obamacare.
I thought, what a nightmare.
What a nightmare that a man who
was tortured for his country
has come to this exceedingly
peevish sick moment in his life
just before he dies, that he
would do something like that.
That's the guy that I voted for.
Mitt Romney,
similarly I voted for.
The fact that he would
take what he pretends
is a principle stand
against this president.
I would like to think that
these folks are diluted,
that their evil
actions are the result
of really being diluted,
because otherwise
it's too disturbing.
- So we talked a
little bit about this
when you interviewed me,
but I thought this
might be a nice way
to bring this all full circle.
But you don't strike me as
like a purely political beast,
in that you care about things
that are much bigger
than politics,
so politics is
just a piece of it.
But yet these days, everything
has become so political.
And I'm wondering, what else
do you think is important
to live a full, clear life?
- Well, there's no
question that my faith
in the God of the Bible is
the most important thing,
and that it suffuses,
or at least I hope it's the
suffuses every part of me
and takes precedence
over every part of me
or every other part of me.
I think that people who
think you can solve things
through politics are just wrong.
The math is wrong.
It's utopianist scheme no
matter how you slice it.
Whether you think you can do it
through a totalitarian
communist state
or you have some illusion
that you can do it
in any other way.
Look, I think the
founders made this clear,
and this is what
we've ceased to teach,
Tocqueville saw it that,
in my book, if you can keep it,
I talk about my friend Os
Guinness came up with the term
but he calls it the golden
triangle of freedom.
"And he says that
freedom requires virtue."
Now, it's an interesting thing.
Every single one
of the founders,
Ben Franklin, Thomas Jefferson,
every single one of them
understood that concept,
that self-government
and liberty,
which had never been pulled off
in the history of the
universe ever once,
was possible if the citizenry
were basically virtuous
or if there was a
culture of virtue.
So they all understood this,
they all wrote about it
and I put most of those
quotes in my book,
so that you read it and
you go, that's wild.
They all believed it,
there was no argument,
but we're not
teaching it in school.
So you think, so
freedom requires virtue,
then the founders also
believe that virtue
in turn required faith.
Now, they didn't
stipulate Christian faith,
nor did they dare say
faith can be enforced,
because they didn't
believe in that,
but had seen that virtue needs
to be held up by something.
Why do I do the right thing
when no one is looking?
Why do I not loot when
I might not get caught?
Well, because I answer
to a higher authority.
They all observed this.
Franklin observed
this most directly
in all the preaching
of his friend,
George Whitefield,
this evangelists.
When revival broke
out, crime went down,
domestic abuse went down,
self-government went up.
They saw this happening up
and down the 13 colonies,
and they saw that
faith was central.
But then the third part,
freedom requires virtue,
virtue requires faith, faith
in turn requires freedom.
In other words, faith
cannot be forced,
it cannot be enforced,
it can be encouraged,
we can celebrate faith,
but there's nothing
the government can do
to force you or me
to believe something
about these transcendent
things or to act virtuously.
Maybe can force us to act
virtuously at the end of a gun
but then it's no longer virtue,
so in fact, they can't do that.
So the founders got this,
and they really
understood something
that had never been
understood before.
And so, if you think about it,
there's just no escaping it.
Once you cease teaching
respect (indistinct)
or the government,
once cynicism comes in, the
whole thing falls apart.
And so I just,
I feel hopeful, but
I think that it's,
we're in a real
battle right now.
There's no question about
it that every part of the,
what I really meant to say
was that the culture is the
thing that holds it together.
You can vote for all
the right people,
but if the culture itself,
if what you see on TV,
if what is out there in the
culture and in the schools
doesn't reinforce this idea,
somebody I forget who called
it the habits of the heart.
If we're not taught
to love our country,
there's a part in my book,
"If You Can Keep It."
I remember in fifth grade, an
old teacher, her last year,
let us outside on June 14th,
was one of the last
days of school,
to celebrate flag day.
And it was this sacred
moment and she never said it.
But she was teaching
us to love our country,
to respect the flag
in the most sweet way.
We've really ceased
doing that mostly.
And I think when you
see stewing that,
politics will fail you,
culture is upstream of politics
and conservatives and Christians
have notoriously abdicated
the world of culture
as important as politics is.
And you know it is,
and I know it is,
we can't advocate culture,
which is why I do
silly things like write
"Donald the Caveman" books,
and have a talk show where
I talked to novelists,
and so on and so forth.
'Cause I actually think that
is the part of the battle
where we have failed
most miserably.
- Metaxas, I will keep
fighting alongside of you.
What do you think of that?
- I'm so happy to
finally get to know you
and it really,
you're an encouragement
to me and to many people.
So thank you for what you do
and thanks for giving me an
opportunity to rant and rave.
I just needed to get
those things off my chest.
- Likewise, my pleasure.
And we're gonna link
down to all the books.
Wait, what's your Twitter?
I'm not remembering it
off the top of my head.
It's jus Eric Metaxas-
- Eric Metaxas.
- That's it?
It's just my name,
Eric Metaxas, Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram, Eric Metaxas.
And YouTube channel.
- (indistinct) my friend.
- Thank you so much, thank you.
(soft piano music)
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.